flaming ball of fury dist war oh no
flaming ball of fury what is it time to
eat we are playing the Alpha of a brand
new game called besides what's that it's
called beseech do I come to your house
and tell you how to pronounce
we're playing visage it's cool it looks
like we're actually playing a game today
bros how about that so you have this
little box and then you add more boxes
to it it's almost like real life really
if you think about it except not really
at all I think you're supposed to build
catapults I think that's the gist of it
and this you may think this doesn't look
like a good catapult and you are
absolutely right all right what else did
we need steering wheel [ __ ] it why not
this is awesome go [ __ ] destroy really
cool now we're going to destroy that
wind Mira
ah but it's a windmill and I love
windmills I spilled some like laser guns
on it [ __ ] I'm too heavy
no what happened I wanted to be like a
guy with a head but I don't think that's
gonna work
destroy destroy damnit
here we go go forth Berta destroy yes
it's so cute
oh yeah we conquered that zone hell yeah
we did it bros all right what is this oh
how old battlefield
so I think in this one we're actually
have to steer destroy
oh no the chief well what what watch it
oh what is going on why are they not
connected it kind of stares yeah
close enough oh god oh god oh god oh god
go left
Oh all right we lost the steering wheel
we killed the trees we are going forward
Oh God Oh God
could we do this without a steering
wheel come on now what we missed it push
me cheap push me
damn yo you have supposed to push me my
arms I'm fallen and I can't get it sorry
it's slow sorry sheep one most what is
that what is this I did not order this
you still do it we can still do it
go forth yes yes fly over there
damn it Berta Berta okay this doesn't
work I swear to God mother [ __ ]
okay this doesn't work I swear I am
[ __ ] out of here no steering
necessary Yolo
no why did you steer wow if I wasn't
giving these cheap as [ __ ] Chinese
products I'd be fine
o-5 live life life life life oh oh sweet
baby cakes
what am I supposed to do just [ __ ] it up
I don't I didn't know how to steer that
took me so long
oh this should be good
what I can put a [ __ ] metal blade go
Berta destroy those Bassets
Wow dammit Berta died what is he doing
flaming ball of fury destroy oh no
flaming ball of fury what is it hey I
never thought I would bite me in the ass
alright BOM shoved God gosh damn it go
wow there we go that's the answer to
death and suffering that's what I'm
talking about and now I'm on fire again
Yeti oops
Wow alright no no my wheel every time
I'm gonna [ __ ] you up just like you
[ __ ] my life up damn it damn it why
destroy destroy
[Music]
bird bird knee whatever your I love you
I love you what uh-oh go Berta Caleb oh
I have to kill everyone
dan this will be tough no I did I did
Maisie Maisie what is up with this man
destroyed that easy if you don't try
then you don't fail it oh I did it
it's so satisfying every time I swear to
God alright I think this is the one
we're supposed to be a little catapult
so this should work no it doesn't now
we're talking baby if this doesn't work
I'll cry the river of up oh my god
Betsy you're a beast you're be speci
this is the beast base to the base base
to the base piece in the peace peace
always
it's too high yeah we have to redo
everything go no [ __ ] you're in your
couch yeah see the beast basted the
Beast basted the beasts oh my god
destroy 90% of everything they said it's
nice
damn it Missy Yolo best of the beasts
best of the beasts base of the beasts
baste it baste this beast go Bessie I
love you Bessie damn it Bessie all right
here we go here goes nothing
go Missy go destroy go Bessie destroy
why if you can't beat them
[ __ ] them foot [ __ ] them up real good
No did we do it did we do it all we're
so close that almost you know what if we
had a catapult we could totally pull it
up oh my god Bessie you are my Sun pie
[Music]
you we did it we did I feel like I'm
cheating but hey why not
all right hey I'll [ __ ] it up all right
damn it
okay let's try and stride out might be
too heavy
yep okay well at least we have that down
kind of so now we need to figure out how
to get the wood and I'll only get the
wood wood get the wood the [ __ ] up there
there must be some lift like a fork
truck or some shade that we need to
build and then we lift you up how the
[ __ ] hell and well we have a grabber
so we could grab them what if we what if
we make it simple for our self and just
do the grabber and then we [ __ ] try
and fly up or some [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
because how else would I get the grabber
to move up
let's do it the pretty pie way the
stupid-ass [ __ ] way seriously if this
works I'll I'll cry tears of joy will it
lift
epic music please don't dent it oh [ __ ]
which one are flying there we go didn't
oh my god [ __ ] being smart when you can
just yell oh I'm gonna have to end that
there he brought me to play more with
that like button it helps me out a lot
and thank you for watching as always
stay awesome bros
[Music]